hey guys i'm ryan right and i'm katie do
blah Katie and I are so close to each
other's faces today hey we're gonna
check out the trailer for Krampus sorry
Adam Scott and toni collette dream team
that's what I say so yeah with Halloween
around the corner I hear this is like a
hybrid of Christmas and horror Christmas
horror film I'm not sure how we should
sit there just just let's trailer play
my efforts and long as we wanted to it's
the most wonderful time with the cut
this year looks like Martha Stewart
throw up in here this is delicious honey
a little dry well mines delicious mine's
dry do you want to trade its
with those holiday greetings
how are we gonna survive Christmas with
12 people stuck in a house with no heat
and no electricity or food there's
plenty of leftovers Howard beer it is so
weirdest thing like no cars here people
how long can this keep up
I remember this character now I'm sorry
I remember the whole sis
st. Nicholas is not coming this year
instead a much darker ancient spirit
closer hopes elk go kind of goat walks
on its hind legs
his name is Krampus he and his helpers
did not come to give but to take
everybody hold on do it together
yeah is the shadow of st. Nicholas
it's Christmas nothing Bad's gonna
happen on Christmas well I'm not sure I
should respond to that I like the fact
that it's a Christmas horror film
because those movies tend to not get the
best reputation and you got some pretty
good actors in there you do yeah I don't
know I feel like they're advertising is
a horror comedy but I feel like they're
gonna can a lot of the comedy when it
gets to the horror part and I'm not
looking forward to that it might work it
might be a good transition I'm not clear
on the genre here actually the tone is
confusing
yeah it's like is this a horror comedy
is this just a horror film I learned
about Krampus from American Dad really
the first time I ever learned I learned
about it from the office are you getting
yeah right is always talking about yes
that's right that's right that's how we
know who this character is not because
we're indulgent no no we know from
watching television yeah that's where I
get all of my Internet's where I get
most of my information it's not terribly
commercial like you can't say that this
Christmas movie is being made to sell
more traditionally you know Christmas
commercial toys yes like that it's
Krampus it's kind of a weird Legend and
tradition that we don't really
necessarily celebrate in stores here
that gives it I think a little bit of
authenticity in terms of the Christmas
spirit yes I can see what you're saying
having said that it's a stretch yeah a
little bit but I don't know the scares
kind of don't look that scary like they
got some creepy like effects going on
but the scares themselves like this
doesn't look scary to me the the whole
thing with her being under the car
really it was just long enough so I was
like okay
coming out okay it's coming out okay
it's coming out and it wasn't coming and
I was just like yeah but how many times
are we gonna see that in harmony where
someone's hiding under a car there's the
bad guys feet right there but now he has
goat feet and a large like wool cape
thing that's dragging behind him it's
that's kind of creepy you know my
biggest concern is that this film is not
gonna totally work however I said that
about the visit and I really liked a
visit so this could just be the trailer
that I'm watching it's the first trailer
it's not an interpretation of the whole
film so maybe it's gonna actually
deliver what I want from this movie
here's here's what I here's what I won't
tell me what you want I want it to just
have a lot of fun you know like let
there be jump scares let there be fun
spooky moments let there be a lot of
comedy you know just have a blast making
it something about it seems like one of
those genres specifically the comedy
part might be a little forced so they're
taking themselves a little too serious
yeah that's my biggest issue with it is
that it looks like oh come on man you
could have more humor and this is a
[ __ ] Christmas horror film you think
from thing about coffin yeah you don't
have to make it the scariest thing ever
but it's cool that they're making it you
know it's like if there's one horror
film that takes place around Christmas
that will probably be good marketing I
could see how they will go with this
because it's an actual ancient legend
and it's a Christmas legend so it makes
sense as opposed to like let's release
another scary Santa movie or something
like zombie is it Christmas yeah wait a
minute so officially I saw a trailer it
was pretty cool yeah is it Christmas
charlie wow you should have watched a
trailer for that me sure I should wish I
should totally show you watch it but I
like Adam Scott yeah I think he's really
cool he's got great delivery and he's
also a really good dramatic actor so be
cool as I can see him kind of you know
balance both just like you have a really
sincere performance as opposed to I'm
gonna call me your ramen a drama like
kind of just I don't know what I'm
trying to say there specifically I'm
also unclear yeah thanks Katie mm-hmm
you're the best guest I have on the
channel you make things feel good anyway
guys thanks for tuning in to the channel
if you're new to it you can subscribe to
the real rejects you can check out Katie
do blahs Channel and you can follow me
on Facebook Instagram Twitter Atlanta
ESCO I finally got Instagram and she has
an Instagram too you should check out
her Instagram there's like three photos
on there that's accurate no bikini
photos he's warming up to it I'm trying
to get will you post bikini photos in
the appendices probably not really you
seem like you're in good shape I am in
good shape then you should do it and you
get way more followers yeah wait trust
me I know
I follow everyone in abhi are you you've
got bikini pics up
I got bikini pics up I got full nudes
that's are my account cuz I got taken
down but it's good if you put up a
bikini pic I'll put up a bikini a big
challenge accepted